celui-ci bonsoir vous êtes un rayon de
soleil après ses conversations très
sérieuse que nous venons d'avoir alors
ni hao ma bosse au fac moyenne nice le
champ croyait
alors shoot si vous avez fait quarante
films vous êtes une énorme star en asie
et dans le monde depuis la sortie de
millenium mambo et vous n'avez que 26
ans j'étais à taïwan
est ce que vous croyez qu'un jour la
chine nationaliste tchang kaï-chek et la
chine populaire de mao tsé toung seront
réunies c'est un sujet très sensible de
ces démissions des sujets sensibles
suite si situe tout était encore en vie
ils vont pas penser à la réunification
à présent que la politique instable
alors qu'en chine c'est plutôt de plus
en plus stable alors peut-être qu'on
peut penser à la réunification est ce
que les jeunes de taiwan aspire à cette
réunification
la plupart aimerait voir l'indépendance
ouais alors vous êtes d'origine assez
modeste votre père était fonctionnaire
votre mère vendeuse dans un supermarché
est votre rêve de jeunesse était pas du
tout de faire du cinéma
c'était de trouver le prince charmant
est ce que vous l'avez rencontré pas
encore
est ce que vous voulez lancer un appel
ce soir pour trouver un fiancé français
tout six mois chinois wu j'espère les
fidèles dommage alors tout commence à 17
ans vous êtes mannequin est alors un
type vous croise dans la rue et vous
propose des photos déshabillées un peu
comme toi
[Rires]
vous n'êtes pas farouche vous avez très
envie de réussir et vous acceptez de
faire ces photos que j'étais très naïve
on m'a persuadé de faire des photos et
je laissais fait saviez pas de quoi il
s'agissait
c'est ça parce que j'étais trop jeune je
ne savais pas ce qu'est devenu à ses
lèvres ce qui est gagné beaucoup
d'argent j'avais 18 ans je voulais être
belle à voir des photos un imac
alors maintenant oui je peux vous faire
des photos très belle voilà je l'étais
fait et voilà ces photos ont été
publiées dans l'édition taïwanaise de
penta vous avez été remarqué par un
cinéaste locale un spécialiste du cinéma
érotique donc au début vous avez fait
des films érotiques là bas 1 taiwan et
puis ensuite des comédies sentimentales
des des films de fiction des des polars
toutes sortes de films et aujourd'hui
vous êtes devenu une espèce de d'égérie
pour la mouvance ados en asie oui ça va
vous ne souffrez pas d'avoir commencé
dans le cinéma érotique c'est pas un
problème pour vous parce qu'en france je
vais vous dire une chose en france
quelqu'un qui serait aujourd'hui une
énorme vedette et qui aurait commencé sa
carrière dans le cinéma érotique
souffrirait d'un certaine ostracisme
vous ça pas l'air de vous gêner c'est
plus naturel en asie
et c'est non ce n'est pas aussi simple
c'est en fait très difficile au 10e rang
qu'on la première année de mon séjour là
bas âge étaient discriminés il y avait
des articles contre moi des critiques
terribles mais dans le cinéma dans le
milieu il y a des gens qui ont été très
gentils qui m'ont proposé de bons films
et c'est pour cela que j'ai réussi ma
conversion très réussi alors vous
préférez les films commerciaux parce que
vous dites c'est moins dur à jouer
oui en effet on choisit il faut pas trop
y réfléchir
est ce que c'est vrai que dans millenium
mambo qu'on a tous vu et adoré ou si aux
siennes a failli vous tuer dans le bain
oui j'ai failli mourir pour cette scène
mais elle est extraordinairement
charmant mais je suis complètement
scotché là je dois dire j'ai même plus
quelle question poser c'est très
difficile alors après millenium mambo
christophe gans leos carax voulait
travailler avec vous et finalement c'est
luc besson qui gagne et la faire il a
produit un film où vous jouez qui
s'appelle le transporteur dont de
production de luc besson et réalisé par
louis leterrier
alors c'est l'histoire d'un transporteur
de cargaisons hautement confidentielles
il obéit ans exactement comme la mental
non666 non non on a décidé du besson et
nous que l'on faisait pas les mêmes
films la regarde le transporteur en
question est lobé ya trois règles à ne
poser aucune question ne pas ouvrir le
colis qu'il transparaît et la troisième
règle ne pas enfreindre ouais les mecs
précédente employés ouais et mentale nos
personnages ce ne sont pas des emplois
c'est vrai c'est la grande différence
voilà alors ce transporteur donc
transport des cargaisons hautement
confidentielles et un jour dans le
coffre d'une voiture
il vous trouve dans un sac c'est moi
c'est lui
alors le tournage c'était un cauchemar
parce qu'il y avait une taïwanaise c'est
vous il y avait un français c'est
françois berléand un anglais et un
américain
paris quelle langue sur le tournage
scintillaient le langage du corps
à
pas de lui dire un truc très
sérieusement je suis aussi les yeux dans
les yeux je me fous de votre film mais
j'avais très envie de vous rencontrer
merci de nous soutenir
merci beaucoup
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu